so after brad leaves um
then then it's sharon because aj comes
in
good riddance honestly i'm i was waiting
for that man
aj i wasn't a fan yeah aj and danny came
in
danny uh you know everyone's gonna call
him a chipotle bag and all that
that guy nice i'd that's good i didn't
hear that
that's like the standard covered in
tattoos roast online anymore
no okay you know fair that's the old one
that's like 2014.
dude
[Laughter]
unapologetic boomer he i think i think
that dude is actually a lizard
yeah like for real no he he looks like a
ralph from monsters inc
like that's perfect that's exactly what
i was thinking about like
uh like aerodynamic head yeah and when
he sits in the interview room and his
eyes kind of like
yeah they're kind of going different
like it's almost like you're looking
around at like two cameras at once
and you're like what is this and he's
like
i don't know man he he kind of freaked
me the [ __ ] out yeah a little bit like
with how hard he pursued lucinda it's
like dude it's been
one day yeah i just want to know if she
likes me yeah like to tell
tell us so we can stop wasting our time
and it's like dude
just pump the brakes a little bit i love
how
[ __ ] cool aaron was through that
whole thing he's just
yeah making fun of him yeah and then
when he got all knotted i was like john
man i deserve some respect
he's like yeah it knows comment yeah
i'm sorry i made you feel that way then
when lucinda's like i
don't know what to do he's like you go
figure out for yourself in it
he knew he's playing a lot long game not
even the long game it's like the
it's the it's the it's the [ __ ]
normal game like the pitch
you know like never mind that's supposed
to be a golf reference but i
totally got lost there nice you're just
thinking about golf what would you yeah
i got lost in your bed thinking about
can't wait to get on the [ __ ] green
again you know
it's like your pitch
[Laughter]
no i mean like he knew he's just like yo
this dude is gonna
like rile her up and you know women
don't like that [ __ ] oh yeah no
the women don't like pressure so you
know he's just like oh she's she's got
it it wasn't even pressure it was just
like
i don't know it's like sad a little bit
it's like just pursuing
way too hard it's like yeah it's you
couldn't have all their chances yeah you
know what i'm saying
yeah i don't know he i think it's cause
like he kind of approached
like he fell in love right away yeah and
you know
it was just uncomfortable on the way she
completely annihilated him in the
challenge
yeah when he was all like third grader
and like pied her
and like which why i know thought he was
all being all like
yeah i got a presa you know i gotta give
her a little bit of heat or whatever
and then she she goes up to him with the
pie and she's like
uh you did it to me but i i'm not petty
and i don't like revenge until she moved
on she didn't do anything to him
oh god damn he knew it was over yeah and
then he tried to break up with her first
yeah what a a horrible
analogy oh my god you're like a matte
black
lamborghini i just won't start
and they're all both like and afterwards
she's like
i will say since city does contradict
herself a lot
she's like sitting there with aaron
being like i think i'll find see you
yeah then he's like i'll kiss you right
now in front of her and then she leans
in and she's like
yeah then she goes over to danny and
he's like he's just said to me
because she's like petrified of being
the bad guy
yeah so she just starts flip-flopping
here and there which i think will play
well later yeah when the new guys come
in
and you know the the producer picks
someone who's like
reminiscent of aaron yeah but you know
is either very rich or very ripped yeah
one of the arts
rich yeah rip ripped ripped
ripped rich and then when she you know
when she
then she has to come up with her
reasoning for liking the new guy that'll
be good
but yeah either way that was like some
of the best drama that happened so
far which sin city yeah in between you
know
danny although she you know she was
they're so worried about being mugs
they didn't want to be mugs yeah and uh
so they waited to kiss
and so it's kind of serendipitous when
it actually happened yeah yeah
it was a nice moment it was like
hell yeah you you'll kiss each other
let's go let's go let's keep going yeah
all right and then okay and then no
we got it we're good now and then brad
at home
oh don't stop lay him in the corner
oh but she's got pretty [ __ ]
whip out your [ __ ] then [ __ ] off
all your [ __ ] hole
she got pretty [ __ ] yeah that was that
was
i uh that was a special moment that i
wanted to talk about
sorry aaron and lucy no liam
in the interview room after the [ __ ]
cat challenge yeah
he just looks straight at the camera she
got pretty [ __ ]
and just beams straight at the lens he's
like i killed it
yeah yeah just like killed dude
literally if you were
eight inches shorter that would be so
[ __ ] creepy no
he was eight inches shorter he wouldn't
be on the show he wouldn't be anywhere
near millie
nowhere close she got a pretty [ __ ]
yeah he was like
stop he'd be saying that on the couch
watching the show with his fleshlight
yeah capped off on his penis i bet she
got pretty [ __ ]
he had a great quote dude not to
reference you know
the show on the ship but we called it
man
what the first thing he said
straight out the hideaway you know he
goes to the boys and he's like
i couldn't fart last night i couldn't
fault in there
it's just like oh it's like a side
comment that he makes i'm like holy [ __ ]
it's f it's the fart boy show
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i totally forget about that damn
yeah we had we did that for 20 minutes
yeah
i couldn't fault in there he did it i
was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] we have to hire us
yeah jairo please itv what the [ __ ]
i couldn't fart in there
i couldn't fight in there i don't think
he
ever farted i couldn't smell anything in
there last night
really yeah that's so it's it's
you fought with me on my first day
he farted with me straight away yeah
no that was my favorite liam quote
liam's got quotes bro
yeah he really does you know just he as
much as he
uh exudes you know attractive serial
killer
my man's got quotes yeah yeah yeah
pretty [ __ ] couldn't fart in there
but um uh
i don't like when someone lays it on
thick okay which was no that was hugo i
think
no liam said that about aj oh okay and
he was like
she's laid on thick straight away yeah
don't like that
she did though she did she really shot
her shot
she was she was like it was like every
dude yeah
every dude yeah you could touch half of
asia right here
that was actually pretty good it was a
good line yeah it was a really good line
no i laughed at that liam um you know
what
liam and millie i think are actually
like i think they're my favorite couple
right now
yeah they're cute yeah yeah i'm not
gonna lie something works about his
weird tall creepiness yeah and she's
just into it
and i'm like totally fine so you're into
it i'm into it
yeah whatever milly's into you're
[Laughter]
you and jake now both have a crush on on
liam
jake has kissed more guys in that villa
than women have kissed guys in that
villa and guys have kissed guys
that guy has the most kisses he's kissed
more dudes than anyone's kissed
anyone yeah you just [ __ ]
hello he just doesn't shy away and he
has to add one layer to it by screaming
come here boy
come here boy
yeah that the egg game was [ __ ] weird
yeah
and the fact that it wasn't even an
official challenge someone's just like
let's do this yeah this would be fun so
why eggs why not ice something easier
less gross